documentary bigger than us follows
environmental campaigner milati visan
as she travels the world to meet other
young activists
french actress marion coutier produced
the film
she says the young people in it give her
hope because they have a lot to teach us
they have a lot to say and
just because they're aware of the
situation
more than uh uh
older generations and
and because they act they do things
bigger than us
is one of a number of films about
climate change at the cannes film
festival
where organizers have given ecology top
billing
for the first time visitors to can have
to pay a green
tax it is money that is used to offset
the festival's carbon footprint
is an example of how the movie industry
is increasingly trying to tackle
its polluting practices with fast sets
large crews transportation and travel
film productions can be big polluters
but parts of the industry are changing
provost studios near marseille
offers a more sustainable way to make
films
solar panels provide power sets are
recycled
and lights are low energy i want to
leave a better planet for my children
and sustainability is also important in
terms of marketing
because many movie companies want to
film in clean green studios
so this gives us an advantage on the
paris set of historic drama the
furnished president
this consultant says sustainable
filmmaking reduces waste
and cost we can easily lower a film's
carbon footprint by not using generators
for example
but we also try a whole system to force
everyone including suppliers
to think differently it's essential that
the industry adapts
i'm really thankful that they're
taking this you know this
turn because
because it's it we must
face and act a film festival that
attracts
tens of thousands of people from around
the world isn't an
obvious standard bearer for the climate
emergency fight
but when it comes to raising awareness
what happens in can
gets noticed natasha butler al jazeera
can